and his first start in the big leagues
of 2021 and who knows what kind of role
he could have if the cardinals get
rolling in october and that's dakota
hudson ortega seven for his last 14
and hits it in the air too
harrison bainer in center
and the first out
and the 1-0
into the shift on a hop
tommy edmond and a 1-2-3 for dakota
hudson first big league start for corey
abbott we've seen him a handful of times
out of the bullpen but this is start
number one four seamer slide a curve and
change
lift to the center or take it coming on
and abbott
gets edmond and the batter will be tyler
o'neill tyler o'neill has 32 home runs
77 rbis and a 280 average
oh one hit out to deep right it is gone
he is a cubs
killer down the stretch
tyler o'neal home run number 33
they can't get him out
he has been on fire and it's one to
nothing st louis
and duffy laces one out towards left
center that'll touch down for a hit and
the hitting streak continues for matt
duffy
a two-seamer 93
looked inside and then came right back
over the inside corner well thrown by us
and the one-two pitch
uh check swing and did he offer he's out
called out by the home plate umpire and
you watch on tv to be behind the plate
with them hitting look at here we got a
knock boys
get down the line look at that speed
i feel like i should put something on
now
yeah that's what i'm talking no we're
not going to do anything with the
pitcher
and a ground ball hit to short de young
up with it
and he makes the play
here it comes
high and outside ball four lead off walk
[Applause]
here's a swing and a miss on a curve
pick off throw to first not in time
okay kind of got stuck in the mud there
a little bit he's out yeah
well that'll work
just been on a tear since then
and for ian happ as that one drops in
front of lars nutbar
the tear has been the same
for him room on the right side of the
infield
double play ball edmond de young
and they turn two
swinging a miss and a strikeout number
three for dakota hudson that brings
o'neill to the plate he can hit them out
anywhere any ballpark
oh neil again out to left he's got a
second tonight
tyler o'neill home run number 34. he's
been up twice
and it's a pair of home runs
is this guy locked in or what
and that's a base hit into right field
off the bat of lars new bar
off the end of the bat and a base hit
nupar rounding second on his way to
third
harrison bader with a base hit into
center runners at the corners now for
the cardinals in two down
on the ground softly hit alcantara
gobbles it up throws him out
pitch way inside ball four to alcantara
so a lead off walk here to begin the
fifth inning for the cubs
[Applause]
swinging to miss kisner is gone
they'll finish it off the count of three
and two
and here's comes the uh
fastball on the south side behind walk
number two for
the
[Music]
i'm uh get a cory abbott car
this pitch is down low he has just
walked raphael ortega
and that is back to cabrera out there
the turn nice turn tommy edmond the
cardinals turn their second double play
3-2
and that's inside good job by half 3-1
and that one misses and cabreras walked
three in the inning right he's 274 the
lefties 174 against mcfarland
trace thompson batting out an extra base
knock could tie this game a home run
could give the cubs the lead 2-1
thompson weights
and that ball's drilled out towards left
center field that one back on its way
god
trace thompson and just like that the
cubs have a 3-2 lead his third of the
year and he blasts one out to left
center
the one
o'neal with the fly ball out to deep
left again
and that's off the base of the wall
racing to second
have a night tyler o'neill pair of home
runs and now a double off the wall
so the infield in and lies newt barr
with one out runner at third
newt barr a base head in the center and
the game is tied at three
lars
nude bar
here's a line drive to short backhanded
on the grass by de young long throw not
in time
whack went into the right field corner
here
up the middle
and a swing and a miss in the strikeout
for reyes
[Applause]
bunting against the shift and a beauty
oh mr horton i love seeing that oh you
bet
[Applause]
bouncer to first schwindel will take
it my goodness
he's got him right on the top of the
right knee
missed by a lot
so now with one out to aboard
the 2-2
he struck him out
andrew miller back-to-back case
to two
in the air center field towering fly
ball ortega near the wall jumps
and he makes the catch
he steals a homer
from paul goldsmith he had it lined up
and pulled it back nice play now tither
o'neal
into the shift in an air o'neal will be
aboard
at bert deals
checks wing and he went struck him out
good job
the other way right field that'll touch
down fair ball
and towards the corner wilson heading to
second and he's got himself a double now
rafael ortega 33 runs batted in 11 home
runs
3-2 pitch
and a base hit to left
o'neal
fires to the plate it's a strike he is
out
he's done everything tonight
two home runs a double a stolen base and
let's just add an outfield assist to
keep the game tied at three
a 3-0 pitch andrew kisner
and the winning run is aboard 901
pitched to shoshov
base head in his center and welcome back
a bullet up the middle off the bat of
sosov
both sides of the rivalry on their feet
throughout bush stadium goldschmidt is
over four tonight trying to change that
here
and the 1-1
base hit the cardinals will win it
goldie
comes through
friday night fun harry bush
the cardinals walk off the cubs
[Applause]